John Smoltz is set to join us and he'll
be on the call tonight on Fox and John
joins us on the program
I hear you're golfing today where where
are we golf inton a today is
Congressional oh are all tomorrow
our TJ all right so do you call up or do
you have an assistant calling up that
says hey John Smoltz Hall of Famer would
like to play golf today no I call up I
call up I got a lot of you know you meet
the right guy he knows everybody who
knows everybody next thing you know
you're you're hooked up but it felt like
I mean this is the life of a pitcher
starting pitcher is the best life you
can possibly have in sports right four
days ago
right greatest job in America if you do
it well not so much if you don't got to
wait too long to and that's why you know
when the life of 14 years as a starter
and they said yeah we want you to close
now like I wouldn't it didn't and man
has to sure about that but it all worked
out
did you ever golf on a day you pitched
yeah but never as a starter
so as the closer goes you don't know
when you're going to pit so you
basically get it done in the morning and
you pitch 10 o'clock at night so if you
know my theory was if I couldn't get 3
outs at 10 o'clock at night something
was wrong take a nap get ready it was
great it end up being great I played
more golf as a closer than when I played
as a starting pitcher just because you
don't know when you're gonna pitch so my
manager was cool with it
55 saves up for the first year they
didn't really have an issue with it
after that do you think you would have
come up as like Rivera and been a closer
if you'd have known you could have
played as much golf as you did as a
closer now that would have been yeah
that would have been a little different
if I do what those three years are gonna
be like but there's still nothing like
being a starter there's I love the
structure I love knowing everything that
I was going to do when I was going to do
it you're when you're a closer you go by
the seat of your pants
thing it's just not my personality but I
adjusted for that short time frame is
this a must-win situation for the Astros
no it is it is yeah two things always
hate it when we got ourselves in these
situations more times than I care to as
it did when I was playing his uh-oh you
know with what we have to that's a
that's a bad statement and or our backs
are against the wall we have nothing to
lose that's a false statement but what
you do know when you come into a series
like this when you're favored which we
were favored a lot is you have to win
and technically it's not you know an
elimination game so you can always say
that that's not the case but yes the
Astros have to win tonight they've got
to in my mind they've got to have this
statement we just need Cole and
Verlander to pitch one more and we'll
take our chances I mean that's what they
got to have that's got to be there their
statement because if they win the night
they're guaranteed Cole and then to see
what happens after that
I find it interesting that the Nationals
were not given much of a chance Astros
the biggest favorite since 2007
then the Astros lures lose the first two
games so the Nationals went from there's
no pressure on them - now it feels like
there's a little pressure on them
because now they're the favorites to win
the World Series does that change their
style at all not really but it's a great
great position to be in you know
unfortunately doing these games now as a
broadcaster I have to be reminded of the
1996 Yankees Braves World Series that my
man Joe Buck likes to bring up just for
context and reality is that we won the
first two games on the boat came home
and didn't win another game so you know
in sports managers teams coaches they
will use past experiences to remind
everybody that this can happen no matter
what the stats say you know the hardest
thing to do is close out a series so as
excited and they should be the fan base
here is probably now over there a little
bit of a can you believe this
feeling and they're looking at finding a
way to win two out of three games this
is a hot team it's a great story you
couldn't write this script and in LA but
as they know it's going to take some
going to take the same kind of playing
execution that they have been able to
show over the last month to beat the
Astros if you could have the stuff of
any of the pitchers in this series who
would you take Wow I mean it's so hard
for me to click between Strasburg and
Kol I mean Strasburg to me ever since I
you know the world's not fair for him in
the sense that he breaks into the scene
he strikes out 14 guys in his eye I did
the game for him ob network and I said
going into the game I'm not getting
caught up in this type this is an
overhyped machine this guy has no chance
to live up to a people of building this
up is a greatest artist I said I'm not
getting involved in it and it's not
going to get it I I was so locked in so
involved he struck 14 guys out and
unfortunately for him the rest of his
career has been in most people's eyes
what he hasn't done and he finally and
this year has been able to break through
he's so nasty so unassuming with where
most people you know would love the
attention maybe not so much for him and
between him and Cole I mean you got your
pick of the litter you got a mission you
got like if you had to come you could
combine the four of these guys and make
like the terminator of pitchers you know
you take the motor of Scherzer you take
the ten ten speed bike gear of Verlander
and what he can do from the beginning of
the game to the end of course Cole has
reinvented himself into the most
dominant pitcher we've seen in a long
time and have you got Strasburg that
could basically tell the hitter I got
four pitches I can tell you what's
coming in tonight we're talking to John
Smoltz Hall of Famer and full-time
golfer part-time broadcaster for a fox
and the basely Baseball Network does Joe
Buck go and play golf with you or just
he what does Joe do he does we played a
few times just a real
call for obviously best in the business
of what he does so you know I get I get
Kevin Millar out here Mark DeRosa I've
got my cronies out here that basically
you know Kevin's good for good he's good
for the for the uber money maillard
loves to talk about showering with guys
though John just so you know he always
tells me the worst body he ever showered
with you want to weigh in on that he
would tell you yes oh he's a better man
than I am
yeah yeah he said shilling his first
ballot we'll have fun today and play
nice John all right I will thank them
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]